everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today we're going to be
going over a game between tall and
Vladimir semaj n' now this is from the
1956 Russian Championships both players
extremely talented tall being one of the
greatest tactical minds in chess ever in
Vladimir semaj him being one of the
strongest Russian grandmasters to ever
come out of Russia which is saying a lot
considering Russia has an immense amount
of talent pool that comes out of Russia
each year and this is an exciting game I
really like to study a lot of famous
chess games tall being one of my
favorite players just because he is so
relentless in the way that he attacks
he's super aggressive and in this game
he does just that he pretty much just
throws out typical moves that you would
see in a chess game it just goes after
his opponents King the entire game so
it's really fun to watch it at the same
time it's fun to analyze so hopefully
you guys will enjoy the game and at the
same time we'll learn something from it
tall playing the white pieces started
with E for responded by C 6 d 4 and D 6
now a lot of times in play now you'll
just see pawn to d5 the con but Vladimir
didn't have a lot of success at this
time with pawn to d6 so it's not a bad
move kind of a waiting move not trying
to really control this earn the board
right now at the same time he is letting
tall pretty much dominate the center so
as most top level players do if you're
going to allow them to dominate the
center they're going to do do just that
tall now plays Knight to c3 again just a
simple development move you always want
to get your minor pieces involved into
the game early typically you'll get your
Knights involved before your bishops in
this case c3 and f3 are typical places
for your knight just because they can
not only defend your pawns in the center
but also attack different squares in the
center as well so this square here on d5
is being attacked as well as defending
this pawn here on e4 so a great square
for the knight here on c3 now black
again decided to develop his Knight to
f6 great move here again attacking this
square on d5 and also attacking this
pawn here on e4 now tal now plays pawn
to f4 which makes a lot of sense again
trying to attack the center but he could
have also played Knight to f3 now this
is kind of a safer move both there
you know fine moves both are attacking
the center trying to gain center control
but f4 is a lot more aggressive and kind
of like I told you tall is a super
aggressive player so anytime there's a
choice between a safe and an aggressive
move he's pretty much going to take the
aggressive route so f4 very good move
also very aggressive to try to aim and
completely dominate the center of the
board as you can see here pretty much
every square from cc5 excuse me all the
way to g5 here pretty much all being
attacked once or twice from white here
from here blacks going to play Queen to
b6 trying to get another piece involved
into the game attacking the center of
the board at the same time putting a lot
of pressure on this pawn on b2 really
stopping white from developing this
minor piece here on c1 can't move this
Bishop because then this pawn will be
lost so really this is a kind of
two-fold move which you'll see a lot at
Grandmaster play here it doesn't really
matter for white he's just going to
continue with his other minor pieces on
the Kings side of the board he's going
to bring his knight to f3 again simple
development trying to control this on
the board no sides really do anything
crazy right now just trying to develop a
plan typically at the beginning of the
game you just want to control the center
and kind of see what your opponent does
so from here blacks going to play Bishop
to g4 again simple development move at
the same time bringing it in hitting
down this Knight to the Queen here so
this Knights not doing too much right
away and so tall right away brings his
Bishop to e2 getting ready to castle on
the King side at the same time trying to
alleviate this pin here from the knight
on f3 now blacks now going to bring his
Knight to d7 as you can see most of all
the minor pieces and this Queen here
have been developed for black he at one
time will bring either his pawn to g6 or
he'll either pushes pawn to e6 and e5 go
ahead and get this Bishop out of the way
so he can castle on one of the sides and
connect both of his rooks but the
meantime we see white over here and all
he has to do is develop one of his minor
pieces and then his queen castle and he
has completed development here now white
really has two options here he can go in
Castle kingside if he wants to or you
can start to push up the board now
if we really look at it there's really
no other moves that he can do again you
really don't want to move your minor
pieces twice in the beginning of the
game if you don't have a good reason
tall really doesn't have a good reason
here now you really don't want to play
pawn to h3 more than likely he's going
to castle on the Kings side it's going
to be a few more moves before you can
castle on the Queen side and playing h3
really starts to break down the defense
on the Kings side so h3 is not really an
option and so he really has castling on
the Kings side annie has pawn to e5 now
castling on King sides kind of a waiting
move pawn to e5 kind of starts to push
the action is a little bit more
aggressive so as you can imagine this is
exactly what Todd does he plays pawn to
e5
now blacks Knight is being attacked here
on f6 so he has one of two options he
can take it with his pawn on e5 or he
can move his knight now black decides to
move his knight and from here white now
castles on the King set now from here
black goes ahead and takes on c3 and now
White has doubled pawns on the C file
now keep in mind double pawns on the C
file is not nearly as bad as on the a or
the B file obviously you never want to
have double pawns but if you are you'd
rather have them near the center of the
board so this is not the worst thing in
the world and I'm sure tall looked at
this and thought that it was okay once
he played 'if I've so from here black
plays pawn to e6 again he really needs
to have some room for his bishop to get
out of here or he's not going to castle
on the King side and the King's going to
be stuck in the middle of the game
that's really not what you want to have
now if we can't look at this from tall's
perspective trying to find a good move
for him as bishops really not going to
do anything you can't bring it to b2
here bringing it to a3 isn't doing a
whole lot it's kind of out there on its
own not doing too much the Queen the
Queen is really going to block off the
bishop if he comes to d2 or d3 that
matter so where is he really going to go
we obviously he has this knight here so
he decides to play Knight to g5 and this
is really starting an attack that he has
in the back of his mind
anytime he's really trying to come up
with some sort of plan but alleviate
some of the pressure that this dark
square bishop has on excuse me this
light square bishop has on the night
here on f3 now from here black just
immediately takes this bishop here on e
two and both sides trade off and now
black plays h6 now again this night here
on g5 it's kind of a thorn in black side
because he really doesn't know what he's
going to do with it
so he plays h6 expecting you know white
to move his knight back and just kind of
progress on the game from here what
black forgot to realize though is he's
actually playing tall and that's not
really how he plays he's not really
going to bring his fees back instead
he's just going to attack your cane all
day long now a lot of GM's and a lot of
people who have analyzed this game have
looked at this move and say you know
what he really didn't need to do this he
could have easily brought his knight
back to h3 there like in a professional
game if they would have done it they
would have moved the knight back and had
a comfortable game this is why their
games will never be remembered and we're
studying tall's game right now because
tall plays Knight to f7 and no one else
would do that so with that said the King
took on f7 and now we start to really
see Paul's brilliance obviously you can
see the king is in the sin of the board
here with King to f7 so tall really
needs to start to open up the game if
there's just pawns everywhere and he
can't really attack with any of his
pieces then the attack really does no
good at the same time anytime in a chess
game that you're going to sack apiece
it better be for good measure you're not
really going to play defensive and so in
this case tall really needs to play
aggressive so tall plays pawn to f5 now
black does have multiple options on how
he can take back he decides to take on
e5 with this pawn from these six and
then white plays pawn to e6 taking it at
the same time double attacking this King
here on f7 the King has to move so he
takes on e6 and now white has one of the
best moves in the game now I'll get to
my favorite move
in the game but go ahead and pause it if
you can see and formulate a plan for
white and white actually played rook to
be one and this is a fantastic move as
you can see he's attacking the Queen but
if you look at from blacks perspective
there's really not a lot of good moves
for black now if you look at your like
Kevin why didn't he just take the rook
that's actually what he does in the game
because that's really his only option it
really doesn't want to retreat his queen
back to c7 or d8 he really needs it in
the middle of the board so we can kind
of use it to defend his King here you
never want to kind of leave your King in
the middle the board while your opponent
just attacks you relentlessly so in this
case he does take the rook on b1 and it
kind of looks like it is lost kind of
looks like he just sacked a rook that's
actually not what he did though so he
first plays Queen to c4 fantastic move
if you came up with all these on your
own I don't believe you at all but
congratulations anyway and from here the
king came to d6 again who didn't really
have any moves the rook here is just
dominating the F file here and now the
bishop can come to a3 and as you can see
here it's a check and a discovered
attack on the Queen to b1 so the Queen
is going to lose and obviously both
sides lost a piece but obviously white
gained a piece but as you can see here
once the King moves and the Queen is
captured on b1 then this Bishop here on
a3 is going to fall and you're like now
why would he he's just losing all these
pieces all he has left is a queen here
on c4 and this rook here on b1
that's a fantastic point he's better
than we are at chess and so he can do
whatever he wants to but in this case he
brings his queen back to b3 and it does
one of two things one it's attacking
this bishop which if white were to take
this bishop and it is a queen in a rook
to a knight and two rooks that's really
not that bad of an exchange the queen is
you know roughly around a rook and a
knight give or take a pawn or so so in
this case it wouldn't be too bad if you
could take this Bishop at the same time
the bishop can retreat but he's also
eyeing down this b7 pawn which is
not only taking another pond at the same
time tact attacking the king and sort of
forcing it to come to the middle of the
board and that's exactly what happened
so the black Bishop retreats to e7 and
the white queen comes to b7 and he takes
it now as you can see here white is
still down quite a bit of material and
so it has to be very very tactical in
the way tall plays or else he's going to
lose because as far as material he is
down in material so he has to make every
move count now black has to move his
king here so he brings it to d6 and now
white takes on e5 attacking the king
obviously as you can see here he takes
forcing the King to come to the middle
of the board now the knight takes here
on e5 and so then white starts to really
chase the King around the board so the
first brings his rook to d1 as you can
see here also not only did that pawn
kind of force some of the action to the
middle of board but it also opened up
this D file here which what pawn really
wasn't doing anything so you always want
to open up files and the board as you
can see what we talked about earlier
when tal really started his attack the
game was kind of closed there were pawns
everywhere as he's kind of unfolded this
entire plan of action the board's kind
of opened up which is exactly what you
want to do when you're attacking you
want to have as many squares to work
with as possible especially if you're
working with a queen and a rook that
need long files and diagonals you want
to open things up so that's exactly what
Saul does so from here black played e6
and the Queen came back to b3 again
tactically just attacking the King
cannot come back to the D file so he's
going to be chased to the right-hand
side and now the rooks is going to come
to f1 here he would really like his rook
on a1 so as you can see here the King is
going to come back to e4 and the rooks
is going to come to e1 and it look kind
of looks like it's the same situations
before the Kings back on f5 but you can
see here instead of the work being on d1
it is now on a 1 so from here the pawn
is going to come to g4 attacking the
King now there's not very much that
black can do here except
retreat back obviously if night were to
come here and take on g4 then this
Bishop would be hanging if the King
takes here on g4 then the knight would
be hanging neither those are good as we
talked about before it'd be much better
for tall if he has a queen and a rook
versus two minor piece and two Brooks
especially since both of these rooks
back here have not moved the entire game
so obviously as we've talked about many
other videos it's not always how many
pieces you have that's how many active
pieces you have it in this case black
does not have that many active pieces
his bishop isn't doing much his knight
right now is in the middle of the board
not really attacking or defending
anything so white in my opinion
definitely has an advantage even though
he is down in material so from here we
can see the King kind of has to retreat
so the King comes back to f6 and now the
rook comes to f1 now as you can see the
King cannot come back to six now because
of the Queen so he's forced to move even
farther so the King comes to g6 and now
the Queen can come into the game to e6
you can see the pressure is really
starting to build on black so after the
King moves to h7 now white can take this
night here on e5 so this is it's
starting to to unfold here but still
white really only has a queen and a rook
there's not a whole lot of firepower and
black still has you know two major
pieces and a you know dark square bishop
in an open game which isn't really too
bad now keep in mind even though the
computer said this is winning for white
this is not an easy game by any means
for white to finish black does have two
rooks and once he gets them developed
into the game and attacking along all
these open files it's going to be up
pretty hard for white twin this
especially since he only has two major
pieces left but from here black played
rook to e8 obviously he wants to get his
rooks involved into the game and
obviously he does have some discovered
attacks anytime he moves his bishop he's
going to be attacking the Queen here and
now the rook comes to f7 again just
relentlessly putting pressure obviously
we can see here that Queen takes on g7
is going to be checkmate black really
has to do something about that and he
brings his bishop back to f8 now santé
he's protecting this pawn here on d7 and
he's also attacking the Queen here on e5
now the queen is going to have to do
something in the Queen comes to f5
attacking this King here on h7 the
King's going to have to move he comes
back to g8 now from here
a white really had to stop and think and
he kind of had to formulate a new plan
and his new plan that he that he came up
with if you can look at the board and
come up with yourself that's fantastic
he really reached the endgame that he
said you know what I really need to get
my king and safety and if I could get my
king and safety and March muffin board
and help out that's even better so his
plan was kind of to move his king like
this kind of the board kind of come into
the action if he could kind of help out
with the attack but in the meantime he
definitely wanted to kind of hide it
behind this pawn on g4 again this is
going to be really hard for rooks to get
to it's always good to look at what your
opponent has left and how they're going
to get to it so if your opponent has
dark squared Bishop s' always put your
King on light squares he can never
attack it in this case his King here
over on this h-file it's going to be
really hard for him to attack especially
if this King gets to let's say h4 it's
really going to be hard for those hooks
to attack at any time so from here why
decided to start to activate his King
now I brought his came to f2 and now the
bishop came to c5 now again as we talked
about this Bishop is defending this you
know square here on g7
but since he is attacking the King here
on f2 it does not really matter so from
here the King's going to come to g3 and
then the rook is going to come to e3
this is very good because he is moving
his pieces and at the same time he is
attacking so he's kind of gaining tempos
here as white marches up the board now
white really doesn't care because this
kind of this plan he wants to kind of
move his king and get him involved into
the game so he brings his King to h4
he's going to hang out there for a while
because this is exactly the gameplan
it's kind of safe here wasn't safe
before but now I can kind of attack an
attack so from here black is going to
bring his other rook to e8 you always
want to connect your rooks even if
they're on the back row you want them
connected if they're on a single-file
you
want them connected because they can
protect each other and they can attack
and cannot be you know taken by a king
or something else so you always want to
connect them no matter where they are on
the board especially open files you want
them connected now from here is a
fantastic move from white and in my
opinion the best move in the game and if
you want to pause and take a look at and
see if you can find it yourself I say go
for it
but the move is this it's rook takes on
g7 if you kind of look at its kind of
strange first time I looked out like
that that's kind of weird you have two
major pieces left your opponent has two
rooks and a bishop you really need
pieces to attack and you're going to
sacrifice one of your strongest pieces
left on the board why would you ever do
that and he does it because he had a
game plan he realized he's going to take
this pawn he's going to take this bishop
and he's going to either take this pawn
or this pawn on a7 for that trade and he
knows it doesn't matter if he takes this
pawn on c6 or a seven he's going to have
a passed pawn it could be on the a foul
or the C foul he's going to have a
passed pawn so he decides he can pretty
much with his King here on h4 kind of
just hanging out and being able doing
thing with his Queen he's gonna be able
to chase these pieces and this King all
over the board that he's going to be
able to promote one of these past pawns
now I'm sure he looked at this for a
long time and calculated out which I
think is just fantastic because I'm not
playing rook takes on g7 but that's why
tall's a lot better than I am at chess
so as you can imagine black has to
recapture on g7 and the Queen comes to
c5 capturing the bishop obviously
attacking both the pawn here on a7 and
the pawn here on c6 now unfortunately
for black this is going to be a tough in
game for him
typically two rooks against a queen is
not bad the only problem is it's going
to be really hard for black to do much
it's going to be hard for one from the
tool to attack this candle but at the
same time anytime since this black King
is out in the open and there's really no
protection
anytime these black rooks
move why can kind of swoop in and double
attack attack both the king here on g7
and one of the rooks so he has to be
very careful that he doesn't lose one of
his his rooks to a fork here so right
now black has to decide which pawnees
going to the Fed personally I would play
rook to e7 I think it's much easier to
kind of stop the pass pawn on the sea
fowl because it kind of is in the middle
the board the a file over here it's
pretty much kind of segregated from
everything else it's really going to be
hard to stop a pass to a pawn over here
the Queen can pretty much dominate the
center of the board and the rooks can't
get over there but in any case in the
actual game the rook came to e6 and
white played Queen takes on East a7 she
as you can see here this a pawn is ready
to go just straight up the entire board
at the same time he is checking this
King here on g7 the king is going to
come to g6 obviously he wants to come to
the most protected place possible if he
comes to the eighth-ranked
that does him absolutely no good the
Queen's going to come to a 8 getting
ready to come to the action if he needs
to and at the same time he's still on
this a foul so we can just push up this
pawn anytime he wants to now from here
the King's going to come back to f6 and
then white starts his journey up the
board with pawn to a5 now you can pause
and look at it I've analyzed it and read
a lot of other people's analysis of the
game it's really hard for black to stop
this pawned
coming up the a file even though he has
two rooks there's not a lot of great
moves where he can stop this a a pawn
going up the board the King does come to
e5 trying to centralize it trying to
make his way over it's kind of a you
know a futile point here but the pawn is
just going to keep you on it doesn't
really matters nothing stopping them now
it does bring his Queen to d8 again with
tempo obviously attacking the King the
king is now going to come back to e4
kind of his plan to stop so you know
it's really pointless but the pawn just
going to keep on going so the key now
comes to f3 pawn out comes to a7 and now
the rook comes
- e - now keep in mind even grandmasters
can make you know huge mistakes so white
cannot play something like you know pawn
to a eight and then promote to a queen
you can't do that why because that's
checkmate right there so even though why
it's definitely one in the game and he's
going to win you still have to be you
know mindful of what your opponent has
the taxi has because so many times you
look at games and you think you're
completely dominating and then your
opponent back rank makes you mate you or
you know does something else it made you
always look at what your opponent has as
an attack so from here
Taal decided to bring his queen down to
d3 he decided the one piece that's
pretty much won the entire game form
he's going to sacrifice just as kind of
a a booyah I'm better than you at chess
which i think is fantastic
so from here black played rook to e3 and
tall decided let's just go ahead and
sacrifice it doesn't matter because once
you take then I'm going to promote and I
have a queen and I'm up to pawns it's
going to be a very easy game so from
here black decided to resign the game
which I probably would have resigned a
long time ago but in this position he
resigns so hopefully you guys enjoyed
this game some fantastic moves really
encouraging to see someone at this top
level in a championship game nonetheless
plays such an aggressive style and just
sacrifice pieces all over the board so
hopefully guys in Jordan and learn
something if you haven't already please
subscribe and I'll see you guys in the
next video thanks for watching